you know I was at the study conference
you were I was fantastic what did you
think of it we didn't know what we were
doing it was fantastic okay and dude
does everyone know that Jill tarter
study well what director has a set a
director of the Center for study
research at the SETI Institute in
Mountain View California so we have
three centers one of them deals is the
Carl Sagan Center for the Study of life
in the universe the other is the Center
for Education and public outreach over
the Jodie Foster I didn't bring my
headphones although I will tell you it's
a real can I lived in LA my house used
to be truly Foster's house how cool so
we have that little connection she's
she's very bright she is she is she came
to the house one day with her sister and
I opened it and they wanted you know to
look at it and I see what you done to
the place right I should have just taken
my dog for a walk and let them but now
I'm like don't you love what I did here
what I did in the last conversation I
was saying that one thing that I thought
science could do differently was perhaps
lose the arrogance with which some
people present their absolute shortness
that they're right and everybody else is
wrong or stupid now the thing about city
con was the most phenomenal openness it
was incredible
I had been at a conference in Toronto
with Margaret Race and I can't remember
her last name but these are two women
from SETI and Margaret race had talked
about the committee that she works with
that
looking for ways to minimize planetary
protection planetary protection but this
is what got me also looking for ways to
minimize the impact of us on any thing
we encounter right it goes its forward
contamination and back contamination
well we want to protect those planets
from us as well but that's kind of new I
mean that's kind of Heisenberg I mean
we're thinking before we blunder in well
and also the idea that we do impact on
the experiment absolutely yeah so that
was incredible and I brought a young
friend of Danny Hillis in mind there
because of a thesis she's doing for her
master's degree on protecting the moon
from lunar tourism and the she better
hurry up the enterprise is on its way I
know well no I didn't know what
oh the google lunar xprize which is a
great challenge but there's extra money
for going to one of the Apollo landing
sites as part of the contest rules you
get extra dollars if you if you do that
check out the footprints out there and
in the meantime you're leaving tracks
and that and this part of the reason the
government has decided to pull back on
the moon thing because private industry
is I think government's decided to pull
back on the moon thing because the
Chinese are going to go there we've been
there and in terms of exploration I
think they got that right the moon isn't
than where we need to go for exploration
and learning new things it's a it's a
very convenient staging point they're
still talking perhaps someday about a
polar colony landing site but now moving
on
farther it's been a long time we haven't
gotten very far right so let me just
make this one point which is how open
everybody was they're really really open
putting the new is he dr. Griffin oh my
gosh I'm so bad with names which the new
head of SETI overall oh it's it's Tom
Pierson Tom Pierson right maybe it was I
don't even see ya right but someone asks
a question what they thought of a
certain nova program that had described
you know it was almost like Geraldo
Rivera finding the hoard of gold under
the sewers of Paris they had you know
done an expedition and they were going
to find something that would be
scientifically extraordinary and later
it turned out that Nova had in fact
financed this and so someone asked the
question and both Margaret race and dr.
Pearson said you know what maybe it'll
turn out in another 50 years they were
right and in the meantime they've
inspired kids to love science and to
follow a career in science right and
we're all trying to become the next Carl
Sagan because the cosmos series had such
an impact on generation and a half of
young people who became scientists
because of cosmos we when we go out in
among my colleagues I get that over and
over I became a scientist because of
cosmos my question when you hire people
at SETI or when you gather the people
you want working there is this a key
element then in whom you hire well let's
just say we try and cultivate that skill
and everyone who's been there and we
think about it with new hires and then
we lock some people away in the closet
and let others go out we're we're good
to a certain extent but we do think
about it we do have a center for
education and public outreach we do
worry a lot about educating the next
generation so we've been fortunate to
have fun
from both the National Science
Foundation and from NASA to develop
curriculum for integrated science in
high school and we've got additional
add-on guides for grades three through
nine so we're trying to to get across
the fact that you know science is fun
yeah if Danny were sitting here he'd be
chuckling I mean science
he loves it trying to fill in for him
yeah and that's something that we don't
say often enough we we mamon are getting
grants and the problem of this and my
stupid colleague who said that and my
goodness there's a huge portion of our
population that doesn't believe in
evolution so but we never say or we
don't often enough say you know being a
scientist is a fantastic privilege you
get up in the morning you get to pose
your own questions you try and find
answers no one's ever found before and
you never have to stop asking why you
don't ever have to grow up and that's
not a message and it's not easy I mean I
don't mean to trivialize being a
scientist there's a whole lot of time
you've got to put in to earn the chops
to get the the training to hone the
techniques and to develop the critical
skills to judge yourself and try always
in the back of your mind not to fool
yourself not to believe too quickly what
you want to be the outcome and we all we
all fail I mean we we do a good job
sometimes and not so good other times
but this idea that you're going to
perhaps understand something about the
universe that no one else has figured
out I think is one of the great perks of
being a scientist I
it's the adventuresome that's why I
loved what Sagar said
how tunes that it isn't we're making
science is accessible to kids it's we're
teaching them not to be afraid of the
world not to be afraid to break things
not to go out no actually I hope what
we're doing is allowing them to continue
to be that way because that's the way
they were born they were naturally
curious and adventurous and then we had
a cure for that it's called education
right and we drummed it out of them what
waste not to nurture that curiosity and
that openness and that not having
preconceived answers and being willing
to see what is so here's a I mean I'm
sure that people want to hear you talk
more about study and what you're doing I
have a question though before you do
that which is have you encountered is
there any segment of the scientific
community that questions let us say what
you're about or that considers it a
waste of time are not really science all
of the above
right science and scientists are not
monolithic right
I think probably the majority of my
scientific colleagues would would aspire
or would say that what I do is just fine
as an avocation but you ought to have
your tenured faculty position right and
you should be teaching something that's
standard and do this on the side to do
it as a vocation that's a pretty that's
a little marginal for a lot of people
because I end up publishing negative
results I happen to be one of those
people who get a real kick out of doing
something better today than I could do
it yesterday even if I don't come up
with a yes this is the answer we just do
the search a little better but then
there are there there are colleagues who
think what we're doing is absolutely off
the charts not worth doing I don't think
that's a very large percentage most of
my colleagues are
credibly supportive they just wouldn't
do it themselves you know it's a it's a
funny thing we had a we had a meeting in
Green Bank West Virginia last month it
was the 50th anniversary of the very
first radio search done by Frank Drake
in 1960
he's the weather just retired Frank is
has just retired yes and we were
celebrating his 80th birthday and the
50th anniversary of the first search
it's amazing what we can do today we're
14 orders of magnitude more
comprehensive in our searching today
than what Frank started with that's
that's the beginning of this exponential
that we're intending to ride so we can
actually finally do a search that's
commensurate with the size of the
universe but it was interesting to look
at the history and interesting to see
that when Frank was getting started
there was all of this enthusiasm and an
over optimism we had Lilly trying to
communicate with dolphins and I think
everybody was sort of sitting on the
edge of their seat thinking oh next week
next month right we're gonna can
communicate with an alien species and we
over so that we we actually were so
arrogant right we didn't understand that
we weren't asking the right questions we
shouldn't be asking the Dolphins to
understand our world we should be trying
to understand theirs and we should have
left the drugs out of it altogether well
I'm not so sure about it didn't there
were some dolphins that didn't do real
well with that regiment for sure the
scientists but some of them thought we
should spread the joy right I had this
conversation with Danny you know it's
heightened heightened awareness because
I was looking at I was thinking about
clever Hans does everybody know about
ever Hans he was a horse who was
much ballyhooed because apparently he
could do errands medical sums right his
owner would say what is four and seven
and then he would stamped his foot until
he arrived at the proper sum and then he
would stop well then they found out that
he wasn't really doing arithmetic that
the own his owner was unconsciously
sending a subtle body language signal
when he arrived at the right number and
that's when the horse would stop and
everybody said Oh stupid Khan so you
know horses can't do math I'm like how
smart is the horse what a poker players
call it a tell yeah well you know we're
back in that same conundrum with
unfortunately Alex gray African palate a
parrot Alex died a year or so ago and
we're still pondering over what was
going on
could that bird really tell yellow from
orange round from square I you know I
when I look at the tapes there's one
very famous tape where Alex was acting
up and his punishment was to be deprived
human interaction so they shut Alex off
in a room and apparently the camera was
still on anyway
alex is pacing back and forth and saying
[Music]
he's cussing himself out because he's he
took it too far or that's what we human
observers infer from seeing this tape
now was Alex really ticked off at
himself because he played it too hard
and got punished it's compelling it's
compelling but is it right now I I'm the
burn you know I read annex
where they were testing pigeons oral
what's the word hearing acuity yeah and
their ability to tell you know what they
did was they played them a lot of box
and then they played them a lot of
Stravinsky and then they played them
different composers and the pigeons had
to put them in the box category of this
driven city category did they vote well
all the pigeons got it right except for
one who put books to here today in
Stravinsky category and say and I'm like
I'm not I'm for me that pigeon has spent
the rest of his life I know it was
[Music]
complex is saying but for instance you
know much as I admire Noam Chomsky for
some things I I detest what he did again
the arrogance in the orthodoxy and
fundamentalism of his position on animal
speech because Coco the gorilla who you
know she made a joke and I'm sorry you
did what happened was her trainer was
you know demonstrating her verbal
abilities or her comprehension abilities
and asked her to bring her something
read and Coco brought her a white towel
and the trainer said no I asked for
something red and Coco pointed to a red
thread on the towel now that to me is a
joke and if you can do a joke than you
know language well actually there's
another Coco story that I'm familiar
with it's it was a relative of Penny who
came who was quite visibly pregnant and
Coco looked at her and is penny says she
signed ate too much candy oh my god well
and it may have been a joke as well so
is
this is what I'm concerned about if we
do encounter and that should terrestrial
intelligence how I mean our record isn't
so good no it's not so you can think
about the tyranny of Lightspeed if we
only encounter information we may be
saved from ourselves by the fact that we
have to figure it out and they don't
know we got the message until we decide
to send some reply back so we can we can
try and get smart if in fact they come
here which I highly doubt I think that's
a lot harder than we think it may even
be impossible if they come here the game
is over in the sense that what will
happen will be determined by their
obvious in superior that's the word I'm
looking for technology because we can't
get there so I don't know on this planet
when we have had interactions between
two very different cultures one
technological one less advanced the less
advanced culture has not fared very well
but in fact what we forget is it's the
virus vector that has been so
devastating we brought disease that it
can ask your favorite fantasy what
happens
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you